really interesting human thank you for
coming us I'd like to thank the
organizers for the invitation this is a
very nice workshop I should also say
that everything I'll talk about is based
on number of papers mostly written some
written with I knew this poster
it is a basic setting a convex
optimization problem in kornek form I'd
like to not assume much about the the
cone itself it's gonna be a proper
convex cone the proper assumption is
necessary that was some generality can
be formulated in this way it could be a
hyperbola city cone just to call the
workshop but doesn't have to be and so
the the motivations are behind a lot of
what we do is that as all of you know
there's really excellent algorithmic and
even software support for the case where
this cone is symmetric in particular for
something programming even if what
you're interested in source software you
have more software than you ever want to
try and there's also really excellent
commercial solver which also shows that
there is clearly a business case to be
made for studying as the piece okay
interest and of course there are many
many applications which come from this
decades long story of semi-definite
representable sets and even though this
has been going on for four decades this
is research into symmetric cone
programming comparatively there is
really very little support for for the
non symmetric case interested in
developing some practical algorithms and
tools for for these problems and of
course anyone could all this time this
has not been done you know perhaps
because of interesting so why do we want
to do now symmetrical programming I feel
like this is maybe the one workshop but
I don't have to explain why it is
important we all know that there are
interesting cones that are not semi
definite representable at least are not
yet known to be semi definite
representable and the direction from
which I came to this set of problems is
actually from certain semi definite
representable problems I think there's
even a case to be made that that there
are problems that can be casted as DPS
but doing so much
and I think this shouldn't be a totally
foreign idea I mean we see it is even
just within the context of course
asymmetrical programming you know nobody
in their right mind will solve a second
order comm program or a linear program
by formula let's say a linear program by
formulating it as an SDP over diagonal
matrices and then feed it to a general
purpose or actually you can do that
because most of the better SDP servers
will recognize that it's in fact the
diagonal matrix and move all those con
constraints into polyhedral cocoa
strains that handle them separately and
my favorite example is this sum of
squares optimization which again I don't
have to introduce I can I have a
definition here but you don't know what
it is and you also know that this SOS
cone for the cones of n variable degree
to be some a sum of squares or
polynomials it's an interface
representable for every end and for
every D but if you ever really tried
solving sufficiently large SOS problems
especially involving polynomials of high
degree you have probably also
experienced some practical issues that
are issues with scaling terribly well
very quickly are the running times
becoming crazy or the memory
requirements becoming crazy if the
degree is sufficiently high then there
are numerical conditioning issues as
well our circle back Teresa I'll talk
about more about where this come from
and what we can do about it for now I
just want to say that I think that is to
it although so here I was not sure if I
should put the next slide or not but and
I couldn't help myself so that I know
that there are people who don't agree
with me about formulating semi-definite
representable problems is not symmetric
on programs but otherwise so so back to
non-kinetic comp programs don't read all
the slide I decided to put this after 11
stop just be able to kind of not not to
compare and contrast but just going to
refer back to his talk so in this talk
and everything that we do we are back to
that self concordance setting that he
argued is it's not necessary and can be
relaxed and it's going to work for us
so again none of the first part is
really important just kind of point that
maybe the
so there was some local metrics and
local measures that he mentioned
everything is in terms of the analysis
and the definition and the requirements
are always done in terms of these local
norm balls which are defined using the
Hessian of some self concordant barrier
function so essentially what's important
is when we say that we sort of
understand we know work on well enough
to be put to optimize over it it
generally means that a minimum that we
are we know some so-called
logarithmically homogeneous F concordant
barrier which is a semca mister the
tricky part function defined on the
interior of this and there is a lot of
research that has been done in this
setting that introduced a lot of it just
at a very high level one way in which
the different methods differ is how much
they assume we know about both the
primal and the dual core and then
there's also a lot of difference instead
of a practical performance so what do I
mean by math is different in how much
they assume we know about the cone so
the most common assumption that's that
most of the papers is the following that
we have somehow access to efficiently
computable I put this in quotes because
this doesn't necessarily mean the usual
polynomial-time were there but in some
sense efficiently computable derivatives
notably gradient and Hessian of some
self concordant barrier function for the
cone of interest and also in addition to
that we usually assume that we can also
do the same for this conjugate function
of this barriers with F star this is the
more or less the usual like venture
conjugate from convex analysis except
that because we like to work with the
dual cone instead of the polar corn like
in a classical setting we have like a if
you remember the formula and you think
that there's a typo
so so this conjugate function is
automatically a logarithmic Li
homogeneous cell phone calling barrier
with the same barrier parameter for the
dual cone however as you can tell and
it's defined in terms of an optimization
problem so here even the evaluation can
in principle be a problem should be able
to do this in polynomial time or
whatever but it can still be expensive
to evaluate even the function and it
certainly doesn't tell anything us
anything about the gradient or the
Hessian of the barrier so this is a very
strong assumption if I have to use the
definition the reason we can do this for
a number of cones for example for
symmetric cones is because this
optimization problem actually has an
analytical solution so we can actually
derive a closed-form formula solution to
this and then of course I can
differentiate that and then I have their
your gradients and Hessians for as well
there are plenty of situations where
it's just not applicable in general for
hyperbolic silicones we generally don't
know it right so if we we know an
efficiently computable barrier for the
cone itself namely the negative
logarithm of that polynomial whose
hyperbolic city code we are talking
about as long as that polynomial is
simple enough then this can be one of
the special cases it's sum of the
squares or generally doors or spectra he
drew cones we know and easily computable
at this point of time computable barrier
for the dual cone for K starts in the
case of sum of squares we don't know any
don't know of any efficient liquid list
as well I know we don't know of any
efficiently computable order to make a
homogeneous self-important barrier for
the SOS cone but we have one for the
dual corn from the SDP representation I
got a so come back to this example and
yeah there's a problem namely that the
defining polynomial which is the
determinant that appears in the formula
is not that cheap to compute actually
and then the third point is maybe less
interesting but I was also curious maybe
somebody in the audience knows what to
do with these that there are certain
cons generalized power cones is one
example where we actually have closed
form formula barriers for both the
primal and the dual cone but they are
not going to get bears so they don't
what one is not the conjugate of the
other and actually don't know dual
methods require a barrier and it's
conjugate not just any it's just a very
incomplete list of some some examples of
what sort of algorithms are out there so
that you know the classic natural enemy
of ski book 1994 has several methods
under these assumptions that I had in
the previous slide so we we are able to
it assumes we are able to compute the
gradient of the barrier ration of the
barrier the gradient of the conjugate
barrier and the Hessian of the conjugate
barrier and then Nesterov codon year has
the same assumption under the same
assumption and in feasible start method
which also has the same programming if
we specialize it down to linear
programming or we specialize out to SDP
we get the reservation
the infeasible start through the support
homogeneous cells were embedding it's
just a nice feature it doesn't have like
a strong theoretical advantage to it but
in practice it's really helpful in that
we don't need to for example specify a
strictly interior as long as we can come
as long as we have a point from the
interior of the call it's also not a
strong assumption and so a lot of papers
are missing and unless I'm missing
something the first sort of real
breakthrough in this direction was
instead of size-12 paper in this
primal-dual method the only assumption
is that we can compute the gradient and
the Hessian of the barrier and that we
can compute function values for the
conjugate barrier but doesn't use the
gradient or - you know the conjugate
barrier so this is already it seems like
this is almost fully generally usable as
long as I can really good handle on the
barrier F because if all else fails at
least I can compute functional values of
F star by just solving that optimization
problem that defines that story still
maybe not be the most practical thing
but it's it's something that already
seems global for basically any cone for
which I have a barrier function and then
the even one step nicer paper is our
algorithm is this algorithm behind yeah
from 2015 which is a 102 a method which
also on top of that it has sort of all
the the nice practical bears and we saw
it's an infeasible store has a
predictor-corrector framework which
requires only the barrier gradient and
the Hessian and doesn't require anything
from the other other barrier this also
means that of course I could just also
since the prime not do a method which
will compute primal solutions and dual
solutions it also means that I could
even use it in the setting when I only
have a barrier for the dual cone and we
just
so I only need a barrier for one of the
so here just some some more detail on
this because this is what we are going
to work on search so this method as I
said it computes some optimal area
numerically near optimal solutions to
both the primal and dual problems and it
sort of as I mentioned it has all the
practical improvements and I don't have
any of the details because it's really
actually very similar in spirit to the
things that Levin talked about yesterday
in particular it's it's a path following
method follows a central path that's
very similarly defined to what we've
seen yesterday so the particular the
relaxation of the complementarity
constraint is this equation that the the
dual vector s plus mu times the gradient
is equal to zero and then we define a
central path around that but because
everything is done in the South
concordant framework with the local
norms the neighborhood of the central
path is basically defined as a set of
points where this s plus mu times
gradient which I'd like to be zero on
the central path should just be less
than or equal to some quantity in the
local duo norm so now again if you just
look at this formula formally this does
seem to make reference to the dual norm
and the dual barrier but it doesn't
really matter I can for example compute
this if I just have the barrier gradient
as well as the barrier hessian whose
inverse
but I don't need to compute I don't need
to have any access to any Google they
are as I mentioned it's it's a
predictor-corrector type method and that
basically means it's a Newton type
method in every iteration we'll have to
compute two newton steps and to write
down those linear systems whose solution
is the Newton step again all we need is
the problem data of the a matrix B
vector C vector and then this barrier
Hessian and it achieves the best known
iteration complexity so how do we define
it precisely especially since we don't
necessarily a feasible start so what we
can say is we can start from an
infeasible point which is in the core
network or it will always remain in the
interior of the cone the linear
equations in the primal and the dual may
not be satisfied if they are satisfied
in the beginning it should be satisfied
throughout if they are not satisfied and
their measure of infeasibility will
reduce the algorithm and similarly the
complementarity will also reduce
convergence and what we can say in terms
of complexity to be kind of precise is
that all of these infeasibility measures
and complementarity they reduce to
epsilon times their initial value
this is a very a parameter which
actually means notation of the terror
parameter the square root of the barrier
parameter which is again even if we
specialize it to use linear programming
that's and as I said in in each
iteration we just have to solve order of
n cubed and sort of the size of these
systems which is roughly the number of
variables plus the number of dual
variables and then like as I mentioned
to to actually assemble the system that
we have to solve
we need the barrier Hessians so this
kind of calibrate sort we release of an
efficient barrier computation means so
if I can compute the barrier Heshy and
in this much time in order of n cubed
time that means you know I know I'm
going to spend order of n cube time
anyways just to solve the system so I'm
quick enough if my variation takes much
longer to compute than this order of n
cubed and maybe
even I might have I will still have a
polynomial time method but so this is
all this is also all the good things I
can say about this quite an algorithm
it's it's a great algorithm there's only
one problem and I want to be very
careful not to not to say anything
that's not correct I we are convinced
that dianna we know that the analysis of
the method in the paper is incorrect
because we have counter examples with
two variables where it doesn't do what
it but the analysis says it does I'm I'm
you know we can never be sure maybe they
are easily correctable errors we try
very hard to easily correct errors so we
have our own analysis which is not a
small perturbation so one of the very
early lemmas in the paper which sort of
everything else builds on is its
consequences but but we are convinced
that the algorithm has stated subject to
some minor tweaks is correct so i still
i i i dare not call this our algorithm i
think it's still there algorithm with
our tweaks and with our analysis and we
have a tech report with all the details
of how they are isis needs to be fixed
so so this iteration complexity as
stated is actually correct this is I
think only the energy is incorrect so we
have also an implementation which is
also based on analysis in kilometer
choices and you can download it it's in
MATLAB and it uses a very simple
interface so as I said you know all we
need is a barrier gradient and Hessian
for for the corn that you want to
optimize over so just like it's a silly
example I would not recommend that you
solve this with our code because there
are better codes out there but if say if
you wanted to solve LP just as a single
simple example you can use the usual
logarithmic barrier we know what's the
gravy and the hash you know that's all
you need is some simple MATLAB code that
completely actually that interface in
reality is slightly uglier
homes but for something like LP pieces
for demonstration purposes I simplified
it slightly so if you have up some
MATLAB code that takes a vector X and
then outputs three things one is our
view I mean the interior of the corner
not and if so what's the gradient and
what's the Hessian then this is kind of
all you need and then you call the
solver with your a matrix B vector C
vector and the pointer to this function
and then you get oh and this of course
the user also needs a starting point
just a primal one so something in the
interior of the call it doesn't have to
be otherwise feasible but as I mentioned
if the if the initial solution for
example that you can provide is a
feasible solution in the interior found
and that feasibility to be maintained
throughout
so yeah do I have a slide no I don't
have a slide so so we have some in
feasibility detection built into it
again it's it's a not a very good one
it's it's what I think Nestor event all
would call them very weak in feasibility
detection using the so this is basically
whatever you get out of the and why
don't have it what you get out of this
homogeny yourself to what I'm varying
which I don't have a slide on whether we
can talk offline it just basically means
we have two additional variables
introduced in the formulation to
homogenize width and we know that their
products tends to zero depending on
which one tends to zero the feasible
near optimal solution or there is
something wrong or basically what
happens is a couple of things we cannot
tell apart first number we cannot tell
apart a truly infeasible problem versus
one that has a very very small relative
interior
it's strong but it doesn't hold all bets
are off but if you have so that if you
have strictly feasible solutions on the
primal-dual you know strong duality
holds then this will converge to an
optimal solution even if you start or
any feasible one you just need something
in the cone but if you input an
infeasible problem we may detect it or
we may not detect it the shortest and
most honest answer
so it's kind of a case that I mentioned
this was the original motivation we
actually didn't set out to solve those
problems without SDP and so how would we
use for example our quote for this so as
I mentioned we don't know any
efficiently computable barrier function
for the SOS cone but we infinitely many
such barrier functions for a dual cone
inherited from from SDV and as it turns
out it doesn't matter a lot which one
you use so I hope it's gonna be too much
notation and again I think all of this
is familiar to probably everyone in the
room but just to introduce our notation
so so when we are talking about as the
West polynomials we are we have say and
variable degree B polynomials which are
squared and summed to get the cone of
degree two D SOS cone so I'm just going
to call this the dimension of that
larger cone you and the dimension of the
cone of polynomials that we are squaring
and summing and so what we know is the
usual semi-definite characterization of
SOS an SOS star may be actually the
second one is more readable at first so
that there exist some linear map which
we call lambda this is nothing to do
with the
so the SOA star cone is the cone of
vectors X for which this linear map
gives a positive sign of a matrix that
exists some linear map mapping you
dimensional vectors to L by L matrices
such that the dual SOS cone is this
simplest case what everything is
represented in the monomial basis
univariate polynomials of degree D this
is the and then the the similar
characterization of the SOS called is
that a polynomial is SOS India in the
cone if and only if there exists a
positive semi-definite matrix whose
image under the adjoint of this map is
the important thing to note here is that
this lambda I don't have the details of
the construction here but does really
matter the this lambda operator depends
explicitly on two things one is what is
the basis that we are the second remote
obvious one what is the basis in which
we represent our polynomials right so
here we are saying these are coefficient
vectors of SOS polynomials in what basis
right so this basis has to be faced
similarly we can choose any basis to
represent the polynomials that are to be
squared and for every basis in this
space and for every basis of polynomial
in this space there exists a unique this
is those are the two parameters that you
can freely choose each of them will give
you a lambda and which basis you choose
has a strong impact and a number of
things most importantly that complexity
of example computing a barrier and also
also a numerical value
the first I'll just talk about maybe the
complexity quickly so again this is our
characterization right so a vector so
remember now I'm going to I'm going to
call it X because this is a primal
vector announcing the SOS dual cone
because this is the cone that I can
handle my vector is in the in this cone
if and only if my lambda of X is
positive semi-definite and then they
self concurrent barrier that we inherit
from semi definite programming is this
negative so then we have closed-form
formulas but they are not necessarily
simple they involve inverses they can be
time-consuming to compute and it is the
this complexity of these formulas and
remember what we said earlier is that if
we want to make sure that this Hessian
computation doesn't become the
bottleneck that we would like to choose
a lambda what which this Hessian can be
computed in order of U cubed time in
particular so what I'm trying to avoid
is having to write down this much larger
potentially much larger size SDP which
we'll use basically L by L matrices to
represent the U dimensional vector by
so if if my Hessian computation takes
order of say you to the sixth time then
my overall complexity of the algorithm
is the same as DP if I can do this in
order of U cubed time that I gain three
orders of magnitude I can gain more than
that because every iteration will take
this much time just to compute a single
step and if I can do something in
between then it's something in between
and this is not an obvious thing how can
we computation this much time since
already determined is determinant takes
this much time to compute so function
evaluation so the hanka matrix I had a
slide the night on this and I took it
out the using the straightforward
formulas it's kind of in-between it
doesn't take you to the sixth time but
the straightforward things to do will
take longer than this so something
between your qnu physics it turns out so
in in the univariate case the you the L
is just the L
l would be just de you would be 2d this
is why you can see you know working with
you know L by L matrices means I have
you know D square variables kind of
squaring the number of rows whereas if
we worry about the intrinsic dimension
across order of D so in this case we can
compute but it's not obvious that or if
but it is possible to compute the
barrier gradient and Hessian in d
squared log D time but it requires what
does it require what's it called
specialized algorithms for the inversion
of lowering low rank displacement
matrices if you do the straightforward
thing I don't remember what you get if
you just get the same bound for for some
other bases that behave better
numerically than the monomial basis for
example for chebyshev bases you get the
same
before I show you what we what we did
instead of doing this is I just
mentioned clearly the conditioning of of
this lambda is also going to be
important again
this formula you know this is the
gradient like that what I mentioned the
closed-form formula for the gradient
that doesn't mean we need to form this
inverse oh and this should be X by the
way but nevermind doesn't mean we need
to form this inverse but nevertheless
this this formula still shows that the
conditioning of this lambda operator is
going to be important which explains a
lot of what goes bad when we try to use
for example the monomial basis so for
instance again going back to this
univariate case as I mentioned the
lambda operator is just a Hankel matrix
again and it's well-known that every
positive definite Hankel matrix of
sufficiently high order is you
conditioned and so in particular we
can't even really tell whether our
points are interior so as it turns out
representing our polynomials of
interpolant helps solve both of these
problems and in the interest of time I
don't have the details but it's actually
the nice thing that it's really actually
quite straightforward so a particular
the complexity result is very simple so
what I mean by using the interpolant
basis what I mean is in a previous
example that the you dimensional space
so the higher dimensional space the
polynomials here the sums of squares
polynomials if we represent them just
using function evaluations interpolant
then the corresponding end doesn't
matter what we choose for the lower base
is really then this barrier function and
its gradient and the Hessian can be
computed in order of value squared using
only elementary linear algebra so this
is you know the details are in there in
the paper there's just a simple formula
it's very easy to arrange the
computations in such time it also uses
very little working memory of course we
need the order of U squared memory to
store the Hessian but the addition of
working memory is a little and I should
add the same if we apply the same thing
to say like weighted sums of squares by
which I mean remember if you know these
are the kind of problems that come up
when for example we want to minimize the
polynomial over some say compact closed
basic semi algebraic set using the Excel
that's our hierarchy and then we write
not just you know sums of squares
polynomials but sums of squares one has
multiplied by polynomials that whose
non-negativity defines the region if we
have M weights then again you know the
intrinsic dimension of the problem
remains the same doesn't really matter
how many weights so in principle I
shouldn't take say M times more space to
compute this it makes sense that it
takes M times more time to compute the
barrier functions this is reflected in
our algorithm so times more time to
compute these barrier functions but it
doesn't take any more space so again
specialize and get down to the the
univariate case this basically means
that we can they solve univariate SOS
problems if we write down the SDP and so
we feed it to a general purpose SDP
solver that does not exploit any way
and the complexity of the same problems
due to the six-and-a-half even just for
univariate point also it gets very bit
more variables do you need some
absolutely that complexity no yeah yeah
this is the same thing so the times log
the dependence on absolute of course is
the same and so all of these the
complexity result of course is
independent of how we choose the
interpolation points of you know we just
use point evaluations but where we
evaluate the point of meals don't matter
the conditioning the very much Matan
depend on what we use and here we were
just relying on those popular points for
bivariate point no meows and these
things what approximate favourites for
and it's pretty well I won't even go
through exactly the problem is as it's a
set of good test problems which help us
sort of tweak the various parameters of
you know how many variables we have what
degree we have how many SOS constraints
we have in the simplest possible
settings is you know linear objective
function and nothing but SOS constraints
and just to kind of give you an idea
that so we are solving the exact same
problem using mosaic for SDP and and an
hour MATLAB code we call it art we
probably spent too much time on company
go to them for non symmetric
optimisation but anyway symbols possible
setting univariate polynomial just - SOS
constraints we have many more results in
the paper so you can see that that that
these theoretical results of you know
using less memory using less time really
translate to to practical differences so
what you can see here against univariate
polynomials the degree D is increasing
here and basically the missing results
for more sake are those problems really
shouldn't in the sense that in the you
know the intrinsic dimension of the
problem the number of variables say is
mm you know mm variable convex
optimization problem should not again
the problem is that we are basically
squaring the number of variables and
otherwise really it's it's a more sec
works amazingly well to be honest you
know our code is not nearly that good
you know the dsdp the largest as deep it
can solve has you know five hundred
thousand by five hundred thousand seven
matrices to be amazing that it can solve
it in like nine iterations in less than
two hours that's actually an amazing
result but but you know obviously if we
don't square the number of variables and
even a rudimentary implementation is
going so so you know in the same amount
of time and also just you know the time
per iteration
oh yeah they are similar so we use
similar epsilon tolerance so it's all
like the objective function values are
similar the you know the violations of
these constraints are similar they don't
necessarily converge to the same
solution because these problems don't
have a unique optimal solution either
but you know in terms of how accurate
the solution is you know how close are
we to feasibility helpful sorry to
proving optimality I should mention you
know I think that the previous example
is kind of fair in the sense that we
solve the exact same problem with mosaic
as we do with our code in particular we
fed to mosaic also the interpolant
representation but one could say that
well if I'm going to use as DP anyways
then maybe the interpolant
representation is not the best because
it particularly introduces some density
to SDP saying the monomial basis has has
parse it isn't those Henkel matrices the
basic income it is a sparse matrices
what we replace them with in the
interposed representations of dense so
we could do much better with a good SDP
solver if it has to be solver can
exploit sparsity and we use a basis
which introduces the sparsity now the
monomial basis that disaster for
numerical reason so there are just no
results to compare but we also try this
with the tribution basis that works also
pneumatically very well and most can
exploit the sparsity of the SDP
representation and so here we have
another set of results now most like no
longer runs out of memory we can solve
all the problems and I think in
principle as far as memory is concerned
but still the timing results are very
very different so we can solve much
larger problems and all the same
problems and
the advantage obviously grows as one
more thing I'd like to talk about so one
of the things that that came up when we
started working with sums of squares and
specifically not trying to not solve the
SDPD so so that's West problems without
solving the SDP is that for a number of
applications this seems like a
non-starter because you know what I
really want for example to if I want to
say yeah certify rigorously say lower
bounds on a polynomial or something I
need rigorous SOS certificates those
certificates are computed from the PSD
matrix so it seems like we won't be able
to use our method but it turns out
that's actually really not the case so
in particular there's a pretty
surprisingly simple optimization free
just simple linear algebra approach to
to compute the optimal primal dual
solution will be little additional
effort from the solutions that we
compute
so again just to give the flavor of the
result if we have any any pair of primal
and dual solutions that the algorithm
computes after any number of iterations
- doesn't have to be near optimal just
the reason you have a wouldn't call it
simple but you know polynomial time
computable closed form formula which
gives us the a positive semi definite
matrix it's guaranteed to be positive
definite and it protects down to the to
the vector that you want so you can
basically in post-processing you can
compute the solution of the SDP down the
SDP and one nice thing about this course
home formula and it's not being an
iterative method but in principle
computable in closed form is that we can
even do this thing rational arithmetic
we weighted sums of squares so I have a
small sort of toy example for this just
to kind of show you how it works and
what sort of results you can get out of
it so this is a sixth variable degree
three polynomial that we want to
minimize over this over this hyper
rectangle it's a really simple problem
the last I hierarchy I think converges
at like level two we know the two
minimum it's even rational which is
convenient it's actually formally the
usual problem of you know find the
largest constant that we can subtract
and still keep this polynomial
non-negative to get a lower bound and
they replace the non negativity
constraints it weighted sum of the
squares we can get this sort of
numerical lower bound it's smaller than
the true minimum which is that's good I
suppose but the interesting part is we
can now basically do the following we
can use this certificate you can think
of this X vector which remember is in
the dual
SOS cone you can think of that X vector
itself as basically being the
certificate of the sum of squared nests
of our of the polynomial encoded by s
okay through the formula of the previous
so we can do four instances we can take
you know a nearby numerical search sort
of nearby ration of certificate X just
by rationalizing the the components of X
and then plugging it in into the formula
using let me go back here so this is the
numerical X that we computed and but for
this s instead of basic we throw away
the numerical solution allowed SOS
problem and just plug in here our target
polynomial minus different constants to
search for the best constant the best
lower bound that we can rigorously
certify with the certificate that we
computed with what's interesting is that
in the specific example but also a
number of examples we got the same
qualitative result the best lower bound
that we can display really rigorously in
rational arithmetic certify it's not
only much closer to the to minimum than
what we could do numerically but it's
actually numerically indistinguishable
from the lower bound so getting this
bound using double precision numerically
only a specific it's not possible with
this you can think of this as kind of
like a hybrid numeric symbolic
computation approach to to rigorously
certify lower bounds it's basically as
efficient as the numerical method
because that's still the bottleneck you
know this is just some very easy at the
end
granted in Russian arithmetic and we can
get stronger bounds then what is
possible to
little time left but also very few
slides so this was sort of a main
motivation we spend most of our time in
solving different SOS problems but I
also wanted to just kind of give it a
shot and sort of test this idea of can I
really just you know I pick whatever is
you know my new favorite cone and just
take a barrier function for it and plug
it into our solver and get some results
out of it without too much additional
work so I wanted to try this with this
song polynomials that we learn so much
about in the previous talk so again you
don't even really need this slide
because we learned everything about them
we know their SD represent the holes and
other good examples of okones
semi-definite representable but nobody
would want to do it we could you know
instead optimize over them using
geometric programming or this relative
entropy programming which we just heard
which is much better and but at the same
time we also know you know barrier
functions for both the cone and the dual
cone and so that means that in principle
we can use our code also to you to solve
to say I get polynomial lower bounds
using this song falling on your homes
now it's definitely going to be better
than using SDPs because the SDP
representations are horrible sorry
horrendous but I don't know if it will
be any better than say geometric
programming but relative entropy
programming I think one one situation in
which it could definitely be useful I
mean besides just the simplicity that
really you don't need to develop any new
algorithms or any new infrastructure
just feed the barrier function
in addition to that I think this could
be useful for instance if our problem
has already some other say semi-definite
constraints or other con constraints so
maybe the problem I want to solve does
not actually I still need at DPS or if
we for example wanted to combine say SOS
and song right since we don't know which
one will give for any given polynomial
which one gives the better bound I know
just combine the right let's try to get
a bound using the sum of SOS and song it
can be difficult if all I have is say a
black box over for geometric problems
and black box or SDP I don't know how to
combine them in this non symmetric comm
programming framework it's
straightforward so this is so
preliminary that every numerical result
I have is on this slide I think it's
more just like a very small illustration
it's going to solve some small problems
in particular the of interested in
situations where so where the SOS
doesn't do very well so the degree is
low but the number of unknowns is going
to be large so this is that for the
number of unknowns will go to a thousand
and I'll just choose and to keep the
whole thing tractable it's going to be
as far as polynomials I just choose some
not too many random monomials with some
small random coefficients you can pull
it over simplex so that we can easily
set of this funding problem and we
actually know that we will get a lower
bound right and again it's not to
compare it to anything I just kind of
wanted to see whether these scales and
that it scares the way it should and it
does look like a weekend variables
without any difficulty and just
generally the you know the iteration
complexity and the overall running time
actually increases slower than say the
worst case
Square with New Times Logan over epsilon
is it's already a pretty good iteration
anyway so I think that this will be
worth and I'd like to spend some more
time just I think interesting or say
competitive with feel like the most
interesting part here was that it just
sort of works without even trying like
Justin did you're very a function plug
it and it works so I'm hoping that maybe
you know this will be this machinery
overall could be useful for it so like
whatever is your favorite Cornett you
would like to use just implementing a
variable so I stop here again just sort
of the you know the summary is we work
one is general purpose non-symmetric own
programming tool has these simple sort
of bring your own barrier framework all
you need is again just the actually
interaction of your your function for
your cone and an interior point of the
cone and any particular art of little
case studies the more systematic and
serious one is unity showed that we can
solve SOS optimization problems of the
magnitude especially objects involving
very high degree polynomials which are
potential applications include
optimization these are main references
as I mentioned you can try our code let
me know if it doesn't work this is the
analysis that the code is based on and
then this paper has the SOS application
if you're interested in the rigorous
certification of lower bounds and that
symbolic high grade symbolic numerical
approach that's in the it's not in the
paper but it's in the preprint so thank
you
[Applause]
barrier they use for the song gosh you
know answered it's better offline there
are so many choices and I have to see
which one generated this particular
result it's based on it's not based on
the relative entropy it's also based on
the exponential corn formulation but
it's based on a generalized so I don't
want to write the wrong thing so I'm not
going to attempt but it's based on
what is the difference or the advantages
of this primitive earth in precision do
it very wrongly method sorry no kiddo
so for instance even in the you can just
use it by bearing your only method on
the row you mean you mean like a like a
question do you get primal and dual
solutions out of if that's something
that you need again this depends on how
how much you care but but say like for
this
SOS problems are we going to certify our
bounds what's actually really important
is the the dual so if you I guess if you
want primal and dual solutions
that is that sort of whatever
conventional wisdom how Victor corrector
primal-dual method based on homogeneous
after what and varying that they're
working better performance or the
convergence pounds you would actually
see that in terms of just theoretical
convergence you you get this order of
you know square root of the barrier
parameter we don't we do we do we do
yeah yeah there is many more in the
paper do I have I have some stuff on
this
oh here was the slide answering your
earlier question about the how quickly
we can compute the monomial and the
anchor case but here are some are this
multivariate let me see yeah okay this
is two two variables that's already
multiple I suppose again you know our
interest with this one was primarily
what happens when the degree increases
right also to test the numerical
performance right like like you know the
monomial basis dies but the chebyshev
basis works and interpolant bases worse
of course if you want to increase the
degree to sufficiently high you cannot
simultaneously increase
but so it's the same flavor we have more
tables in the paper with more than two
variables as well but it's always the
same pattern so so say like you know
most icons out of memory actually
surprisingly late honestly given how
large a problem it solves the intrinsic
dimension of the problem is you know as
a couple of thousand men you run out of
memory and at the same time we scare on
nicely
oh I have four here's three three
variables it's also on the slides the
degrees get smaller and smaller because
the dimension of the problem is already
in the tens of thousands in equals 20
minutes actively forty polynomials so
it's the same for you I think I mean I
don't want to overstate this I don't
think this is really do I have I think I
even took it off the slides but so the
you know this this comparison of so that
for N equals one one one of the methods
gives you you know so that the direct
method over optimizing over the
community SVP without magnitude in
general the the speed-up is
grows as so that the ratio between the
two grows as B to the 3 end so
asymptotically technically gets even the
advantage is greater with more variables
so you get three orders of magnitude for
univariate problems its greater for more
variables asymptotics in terms of you're
assuming that n is fixed and D is what
girls hierarchy or something is a
problem you want to solve has a given
number of unknowns but you're looking at
a sequence of SDPs with increasing
degrees the reason I again I said I
don't want to overstate is this thousand
or amazing orders of magnitude we are
really fantastic the reality though is
this data has also a constant which
depends which depends on that fixed and
for a fixed and the asymptotics are N
equals three you know this is your SN
topics you know D doesn't tend to
infinity erratically from dsdp so
actually everything I said is applicable
to any semi definite representable so
that lambda can be anything except for
the how long does it take to compute the
hash Nia do you have a lambda for which
the hash of that negative log
determinant of lambda of X if you can
compute that quickly than everything
works same thing with the formula that
computes the solution of the SDP if you
really need it so you can basically even
solve the SDP by not writing it down not
solving it engine just at the end
the PSD matrix that formula goes it's
for any lambda over eight there's
nothing specific
thank you very much
[Applause]